[Music]
on this tuesday night unruly rallies
targeting justin trudeau
the demonstrations degenerate on the
election trail it is absolutely
unacceptable
who's behind this and how are they
tracking campaign stops
alberta's icus pushed to the brink again
the solutions to free up beds and find
more nurses
the lack of support for canada's terror
victims just piecemeal that you find on
your own global news investigates what's
needed to fill the gaps
and a world first bitcoin now one
country's legal tender we think it'll be
the first of many countries that go in
this direction is it right on the money
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with breaking news in
southwestern ontario where a tornado may
have touched down global news
meteorologist anthony farnell is at the
scene in kingsbridge anthony what's the
damage like
well we are seeing extensive damage this
was a line of storms that affected such
a large area of southwestern ontario but
here in particular we are north of
goderich in an area called kingsbridge
and you can just see damage scattered
about this is from a silo and an entire
barn that has come down and there's
debris trees down all across the street
we're seeing some of these
roofs and sheets of metal that have gone
hundreds of meters
in the other direction in adjacent
fields now there is a widespread damage
path from this suspected tornadoes there
are also pictures coming in from social
media so we do think it was in fact a
tornado that moved from here all the way
into a town called luck now where
there's also damage there's also damage
being reported in port elgin kincardine
where we rode out the storm as well so
this is a dangerous situation thankfully
where we are at this farm
there are no injuries there is some
damage and there's also cattle that have
been all scattered about in the fields
that's being rounded up right now and
that thankfully is the worst of it but
this is another suspected tornado in an
area that just yesterday morning had a
confirmed ef-0 tornado rolled through
just down the street in port albert
that's it from here on a very rainy and
still stormy evening in southern ontario
robin anthony farnell in kingsbridge
ontario thanks anthony
now to the federal campaign where things
have taken a violent turn protests
targeting liberal leader justin trudeau
have become so aggressive that police
are now investigating protesters have
been following the trudeau campaign for
weeks he calls them anti-vaxxer mobs at
one event in bolton ontario the
situation was so volatile the liberals
cancelled it last night in london
ontario it got even worse
trudeau was leaving a campaign stop at a
brewery when gravel was thrown at him
police in london have confirmed they've
opened an investigation as for trudeau
he has no plans to stop campaigning in
person
a few
misguided individuals
who don't believe in science
who just want to watch things burn
are not going to make us flinch from
doing the right thing we will not stop
talking about how we move forward
abigail beeman has been traveling with
the liberals and was there last night
when the gravel was thrown abigail walk
us through what happened robin the
protesters have always been a group of
screaming incredibly profane people
furious with justin trudeau usually
numbering in the dozens but the
temperature raised to a dangerous level
monday when one or more people started
to throw gravel or small stones at
trudeau as he was leaving a london
ontario brewery photo op hitting several
other people including journalists in
the process no one was hurt these
protesters also swarmed the bus before
it tried to leave i watched one man spit
on it and a police officer take away a
man's hockey stick flag after he kneeled
in front of the bus monday night
trudeau's team would not confirm whether
he was hit when he boarded the campaign
plane reporters asked him about it
it might never did
does that matter i think he
died next to you taking your clothes
it wasn't until tuesday morning he
confirmed that yes he had been hit
abigail how are protesters able to get
so close to trudeau
well that's a question that was put
directly to him today this is a man who
thrives on public interactions and he
said the rcmp does have the final word
on safety whether an event proceeds or
not but he said being able to have
politicians who feel safe connecting
with people is an important part of the
canadian system compared to a country
like the us
we see
little pockets
of people lashing out
in ways that remind us
of
horrific events like the storming of the
capital
canadians need to know
that
their leaders
that their country
is standing firm to not let that happen
what can you tell us about who these
protesters are are and how are they
finding the events
robin i've been watching them up close
for a while and what started as a real
mishmash of different groups with
different concerns anti-vaxxers
anti-lockdown anti-vaccine passports has
now changed to include a large number of
people's party of canada supporters the
fringe political followers of maxine
bernier the only federal party leader
flat out opposed to vaccine passports
his supporters see trudeau events as an
opportunity to mobilize how are they
finding those locations well the
liberals have stopped broadcasting
campaign tour specifics but there's a
network of social media pages tracking
leader whereabouts and relying on people
in local communities to find out with
some protesters now following between
communities
it's not simply
that
there's conspiracies around covet but
they kind of pulled us around multiple
issues uh including lockdown including
vaccine mandates um and and we've seen
much like the previous movements like
the yellow west activism for example uh
some far-right groups latching onto
these
movements as they're growing
ironically whatever popularity the ppc
attracts is a political gift for the
liberals or even ndp with any votes that
split the right further again trudeau
said tuesday he won't stop how he
campaigns in the face of what he called
angry mobs and angry anti-vaxxers robin
abigail beeman in ottawa thanks abigail
both the conservative and ndp leaders
are condemning the protests
i disagree with mr trudeau all the time
but it is absolutely wrong to be
throwing stones i mean i can't imagine
that i'm saying this in 2021 don't throw
stones at people because you disagree
with them that is basic that should not
be happening it's completely
unacceptable to see harassment
of political figures of media
we live in a great democracy and let's
act like we do i don't agree with mr
trudeau's approach on many things but i
respect his ability to be able to
communicate with canadians
free of harassment intimidation and
violence and for our media to report on
that
the green party meanwhile has released
its platform with an obvious focus on
protecting the environment in a 101 page
document the greens say if elected
they'd focus on getting to net zero
emissions as fast as possible with the
aim of getting to net negative by 2050.
all new pipeline and oil exploration
projects would be cancelled existing oil
and gas operations would be phased out
and every high paying fossil fuel sector
job will be replaced with a high paying
green sector drop
to the pandemic alberta hospitals are
under pressure to deal with a rapidly
escalating fourth wave the province is
leading the country in daily new
infections and active cases more than
1300 new infections were reported today
there are more than 15 thousand active
cases and 137 people in intensive care
unvaccinated patients are driving the
surge and filling up icus as heather
yorick's west explains the worst may be
still to come
inside calgary's peter lawhead center
the intensive care unit is nearly
completely full i think the next few
weeks are critical you know
i would say i'm very concerned almost
every covet 19 patient admitted to this
icu is unvaccinated still the sick keep
coming so if those cases continue to go
up
and we don't see a crest in that
then you know we're going to see more
and more patients needing critical care
support so yeah it's very concerning
after weeks of silence alberta's
government reintroduced a province-wide
mask mandate friday along with a 10
o'clock curfew for liquor sales but
stopped short of implementing a vaccine
passport system instead the unvaccinated
are now being offered 100 dollars to get
the vaccine alberta's former chief
medical officer of health worries the
measures don't go far enough there's a
doubt that the incentive program is
going to convince many of the people
who've been irresponsible up to this
point to change the mind and i think
that
instituting masking indoors by itself
is unlikely to be enough to bring the
delta variants under control alberta
health services has had to cancel many
non-urgent surgeries across the province
nurses are in such short supply the
provinces also had to turn to
out-of-province staffing agencies to
help we need to have uh some basic
protective measures put in place we need
to make sure that the spread of cova 19
stops
rapidly before we overwhelm our already
near the brink healthcare system one
week into september it's clear that
alberta's open summer is becoming a very
difficult fall heather urex west global
news calgary
hospitalizations in quebec are rising
tripling in just a month now health and
social service workers in both the
public and private sectors are being
told they have until october 15 to get
fully vaccinated or be suspended without
pay newfoundland and labrador will
implement a vaccine passport in the
coming weeks premier andrew fury says it
will follow the quebec model quebec
requires those age 13 and over to show
proof of vaccination to access
non-essential services
uconn is also launching its vaccine
credential system it will be online and
residents will get to choose between a
digital copy or a paper copy to prove
their vaccination status nbc residents
can now download their vaccine cards the
system comes into effect september 13th
requiring proof of at least one dose to
enter venues like restaurants and
ticketed sporting events as of october
24th people age 12 and up will need to
be fully vaccinated to access
non-essential services
fully vaccinated international travelers
are now able to come to canada for
non-essential reasons provided they meet
all the requirements jamie morocco
reports on the new rules
returning home from islamabad fully
vaccinated mississauga resident daniel
kalani is relieved he can head straight
home you can have like safely travel
without even being quarantined right
instead border agents will look for a
negative coven 19 test result and scan
the arrive can app for proof of
vaccination with a health canada
approved shot if your phone dies or
you don't have
access to your phone immediate access to
your phone make sure you have those
paper copies with you
or you risk having to isolate for two
weeks a precaution one infectious
disease physician says we shouldn't be
so quick to ditch even for those with a
double dose
we can't ignore the science which is
that if you are fully vaccinated you can
still become infected with the delta
variant the delta variant has coveted
cases climbing worldwide vin suggests a
modified quarantine based on vaccination
status but according to the canada
border services agency the positivity
rate for randomly selected fully
vaccinated travelers between august 9th
and 26th was extremely low just 0.19
percent
and ottawa is keeping travel suspensions
in place for high transmission countries
including india and morocco a traveler
with a negative test when they enter
canada or 72 hours before they enter
canada is low risk for cover 19.
and then add to the fact that they're
fully vaccinated and you're really
starting to get into low risks despite
how much transmission is happening
locally
for the uzman family the ease
restrictions allowed them to return home
after months abroad actually we had to
cancel our trip once because of the
hotel quarantine the first trip of many
they say vaccinated and again ready to
explore the world jamie morocco global
news toronto
the new guard is the same one coming up
the taliban unveils its all-male
government with faces very familiar to
the country
after seizing power in afghanistan the
taliban has now announced key members of
its interim government as crystal
gomezing reports this new cabinet is
made up of the taliban's old guard
protests in kabul broken up by gunshots
the violence and uncertainty continues
even as a new chapter begins with a new
government
the head of the government under taliban
rule will be mullah muhammad hassan
akhan
mullah khan who is already on the u.n
sanction list has held power before as
the country's deputy prime minister
under the taliban from 1996 to 2001.
6-2001
announcing the interim government the
taliban spokesperson says it wants to
start new yet it is relying on pillars
of its insurgent past the new leadership
is closely tied to the taliban's late
founder mullah omar his son will serve
as the country's new defense minister
and a man on the fbi's most wanted list
is the interior minister that's siraj
jadeen haqqani whose father founded the
haqqani network a terrorist group that
has since been folded into the taliban
the government includes no women and
will be overseen by the taliban's
supreme leader syed khan is an american
senior lecturer in near east asian
studies while the taliban uh acted very
quickly in being able to take over
uh uh afghanistan in many ways they
perhaps were a little bit too far over
leaning on their skis so to speak
all of the tough role of governance is
now at the hands of a generation past
after the taliban seized control in
august western nations have been waiting
to see how the new regime would be
structured and how it would engage the
world it's unclear if this group will
work with international leaders or if it
will be given access to billions of
dollars in aid
threats of murder violence and
intimidation remain as do concerns about
the way women and girls will be treated
or if they'll have access to education
with part of the new interim government
now in place there are clues as to what
life will be like with the taliban back
in control
crystal commands in global news london
still ahead how canada lags behind in
supporting victims of terrorism
24 canadians were killed in the terror
attacks of september 11th global news
compiled a database that shows 80
canadians have died in terror attacks
since another 86 were injured but ottawa
doesn't track the number of terrorism
victims in this country and as jeff
semple reports there are growing calls
for more support for survivors and
families of victims
that's a picture of a jacaranda tree
which was anne-marie's favorite tree
this picture is made up of thousands of
photographs memories of michelle and
madeline's daughter anne-marie she just
had this warmth around her big smile all
the time in 2013 anne-marie was living
with her husband in nairobi working for
canada's border services agency the
young couple was having lunch on a patio
when four masked gunmen with an
al-qaeda-linked extremist group attacked
the shopping mall surveillance video
broadcast on local news shows the
canadian couple at the top of the screen
crawling into the restaurant as bullets
fly
76 people were killed including
anne-marie i was just in shock
and stayed in shock for almost a month
both michelle and his wife madeline
spent their careers as foreign diplomats
helping canadians abroad madeleine was
posted to paris in 1996 when terrorists
attacked a train station killing four
including a canadian she says the french
government went to great lengths to
support the victims even granting a
lifetime pension to another canadian who
survived but their own experience has
been much different it's just piecemeal
that you find on your own following
anne-marie's death they struggled with
everything from obtaining a death
certificate from kenyan officials to
dealing with the media to finding
appropriate psychological supports for
themselves and anne-marie's husband
robert who still suffers from ptsd
dealing with counter-terrorism and
national security is not always just
about chasing the bad guys but it's also
standing up for those victims of
terrorism and supporting their rights
susheel gupta was 12 when his mother was
killed in the air india bombing he now
works for the rcmp supporting victims of
crime and believes canada needs a
dedicated office to meet the unique
needs of terrorism victims you have
organizations or government departments
that have their own individual mandates
you need someone kind of quarterbacking
it
linking them all together and marie's
parents agree they now volunteer to help
others who've lost children and every
september 21st on the anniversary of
anne-marie's death her mother forces
herself to watch the footage the last
moments of her daughter's life i want to
make sure
i need to have this feeling
to be there with her
jeff semple global news toronto
up next el salvador goes all in on
bitcoin
el salvador is the first country to
adopt bitcoin as legal tender the
government hopes it will help people out
of poverty 70 of its citizens don't have
bank accounts and bitcoin is stored in
digital wallets redmond shannon reports
on the tiny nation's big gamble
el salvador is one of the poorest
countries in latin america its
struggling economy switched to the u.s
greenback 20 years ago and now it's
making an unprecedented change
making bitcoin legal tender alongside
the american dollar
application the trendy populous
president naive ukele says using crypto
wallets will help salvadorians bypass
millions in remittance fees money sent
from abroad funds a fifth of the economy
[Music]
but critics say risk is baked into
bitcoin's dna and that big atm fees
could negate any savings made
this woman says she just doesn't
understand it most salvadoreans don't
even have access to the internet as an
incentive the government is giving 30 us
dollars worth of bitcoin to anyone who
downloads the digital wallet app but on
tuesday launch day its site crashed the
president's twitter account doubled as
an i.t help desk as he asked for
patience when bitcoin's price dropped
sharply bouquet tweeted that he was
buying the dip in other words investing
more at a lower price it's actually
madness because what will happen
immediately
is that the
international financial regulatory
institutions will come down hard and red
flag this and they'll be sanctions
volatility combined with bitcoin's lack
of traceability could make it impossible
for el salvador to borrow you can't
eliminate risk somebody has to take the
risk of that volatility now who will it
be it will be the taxpayers an
impoverished country now banking its
future on a currency few here can even
access let alone understand redmond
shannon global news london
and that is global national for this
tuesday night i'm robin gill we leave
you tonight on a high note from the u.s
open
leila fernandez has done it again the 19
year old canadian is off to her first
grand slam semi-final after a major
upset against alina svitolina thank you
for watching and i'll see you back here
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]